-President Trump and Kim Jong-un
met in Singapore Tuesday
for the first-ever summit
between an American president
and a North Korean leader.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
No matter your feelings
on Donald Trump,
he is currently attempting
diplomacy over war,
which is undeniably
the better option.
That said, I do have some
concerns based on some things
Donald Trump did
and said yesterday
and also based on the fact
that he is Donald Trump.
[ Laughter ]
For example, Trump has managed
this summit very much
like a made-for-TV spectacle,
fueling speculation
about whether
it would even happen or not.
Minting commemorative coins,
writing dramatic letters,
and staging photo ops
with game-show-sized envelopes.
[ Laughter ]
Look at that -- it looks
like Trump is auditioning
to be the next mascot for Gmail.
[ Laughter ]
And the media
has responded in kind.
Yesterday, for example,
they spent the day
obsessively tracking
Kim Jong-un's whereabouts
in Singapore as he made his way
about the town.
-Kim Jong-un, someone who rarely
leaves his own country --
this is the furthest
he's ever traveled --
is out and about on the town
in Singapore.
-Kim Jong-un to be out strolling
the streets of Singapore.
-Now you see him walking around
He has crowds of people.
I could see across the road lots
of people taking photos of him,
waving at him.
-We don't know whether
he's going back
to the St. Regis Hotel
or for another stop,
but clearly, you know, the night
is young for Kim Jong-un.
-As you saw there,
he was walking into
the Marina Bay Sands,
a very popular hotel
that has a casino inside of it.
-Kim Jong-un hanging out
at a nightclub in Singapore.
-Good Lord.
[ Laughter ]
Why not just make
an old-timey newsreel?
"Ah, Singapore,
the jewel of the Orient.
Folks here are all a-flutter
about the upcoming summit.
Why, who's this?
It's none other than
North Korean dictator
Kim Jong-un taking a break
from torturing his own people
to pose for a few snaps with
American businessman Don Trump.
Shake it away, boys!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Imagine being in that nightclub.
[ Laughter ]
"Is that Kim Jong-un?"
Now, in the run-up
to this meeting,
Trump admitted that he wasn't
doing much to prepare.
Later, he tried to back away
from that comment,
and, as usual, rambled his way
into talking about
the 2016 election
and Hillary Clinton.
-I didn't say that.
I said I've been preparing
all my life.
I always believe in preparation.
But I've been preparing
all my life.
You know, these one-week
preparations, they don't work.
Just ask Hillary what happened
to her in the debates.
-Oh. So Trump prepared
for this summit
the same way he prepared
for the debates.
What was that meeting like?
Just three hours of Trump
stalking Kim Jong-un
around a room?
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
What happens when
the world's slowest pursuer
chases the world's slowest prey?
Tonight on "Planet Earth --
Sloth Versus Slug."
[ Laughter ]
So, Trump admitted he didn't
prepare for the summit.
The key question
going into the meeting was this.
How would he know
if it was a success?
What does success even entail?
And was asked that question over
the weekend at the G7 in Canada,
and his answer
did not inspire confidence.
-That's a good question --
How long would it take?
I think within the first minute,
I'll know.
Just my touch, my feel.
That's what I do.
[ Laughter ]
-Touch and feel
is not how you determine
the success of a summit.
Touch and feel
is how you determine
whether a blouse
is made of cotton.
-♪ The touch,
the feel of cotton ♪
♪ The fabric of my life ♪
-So Trump said he'd know
if Kim was serious
from his touch and feel,
and yesterday we got to see
that touch and feel
with their first handshake.
The first handshake
and photo op in history
with a North Korean leader
and an American president.
And I'm sorry,
but why can't these guys
find a suit that fits them?
[ Laughter ]
Look at that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
They look like they shop at a
store called Business Pajamas.
[ Laughter ]
Looks like a promo picture
for a movie called
"Honey, I Shrunk the Dictators."
[ Laughter ]
Trump and Kim then sat down
for a one-on-one meeting,
and look at Kim's face.
Is it just me, or is even he
confused at how he got here?
[ Laughter ]
It looked like they
got set up on a blind date
by their weirdest friend.
Oh, what?
They were?
[ Laughter and applause ]
In fact, just when you thought
it couldn't get any crazier,
Dennis Rodman was there
in Singapore for the summit,
and he was interviewed on CNN
wearing a MAGA hat
and a shirt
for something called PotCoin.
[ Laughter ]
I'm pretty sure PotCoins
are what you have to eat
to hallucinate that interview.
[ Laughter ]
Especially when,
for some reason,
Rodman thanked his agent,
former Bulls coach Phil Jackson,
and Pearl Jam frontman
Eddie Vedder.
-Can I thank some people,
though, while I'm here?
Can I thank some people?
All the good people that
stood by me, Darren Prince,
you know, Vo,
all the guys that went with me
to North Korea.
You know,
I'm thanking Chuck Daly,
I'm thanking Phil Jackson,
I'm thanking Jeanie Buss,
I'm thanking Pete Ginopolis,
I'm thanking Eddie Vedder,
Pearl Jam,
everybody that's supported me
all through all these things.
-Chris Cuomo
does pretty good there
until his eyebrows
shoot up to his hairline.
[ Laughter ]
Man, the news these days really
feels like a Mad Lib from 1999.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
In fact,
after watching the summit,
you might actually think
you O.D.'d on PotCoins
from how often Trump,
a man who has fought
with everyone
from allies to war heroes,
complimented brutal dictator
Kim Jong-un.
-Very good.
Very, very good.
Excellent relationship.
Thank you.
He's got a great personality.
He's a, you know, funny guy.
He's a very smart guy.
He's a great negotiator.
Well, he is very talented.
Anybody that takes over
a situation like he did
at 26 years of age
and is able to run it,
and run it tough.
-What are you talking about?
[ Laughter ]
This is a guy
who starves his own citizens
and assassinates people
with antiaircraft guns.
You're talking about him like
he started Apple in his garage.
[ Laughter ]
But I guess it shouldn't
surprise me that
Trump's idea of talent is
getting rich by taking over
your dad's business.
Trump was born on third base,
whereas Kim was born
on third base,
and then shot the third baseman.
[ Laughter ]
In fact, Trump seemed as
interested in looking forward
at potential business
opportunities in North Korea
as he was in getting Kim
to give up his nuclear weapons.
-As an example,
they have great beaches.
You see that whenever
they're exploding
their cannons into the ocean.
[ Laughter ]
I said,
"Boy, look at that beach.
Wouldn't that make
a great condo behind?"
And I explained, I said, "You
know, instead of doing that,
you could have the best hotels
in the world right there.
Think of it
from a real-estate perspective."
-He accidentally told
a great [bleep] joke.
[ Laughter ]
I mean...
[ Cheers and applause ]
..."They have great beaches.
You can see it
when they're exploding
their cannons into the oceans"
is a great [bleep] joke.
[ Laughter ]
That would be like me
coming to work today and saying,
"I accidentally
signed a treaty."
[ Laughter ]
Even when he's in the middle of
a summit over nuclear weapons,
he's still trying to sell
a [bleep] hotel timeshare.
"If you give up
your nuclear weapons now,
you can stay one night free at
my new Trump Hotel Pyongyang."
[ Laughter ]
But again,
diplomacy with North Korea
is undeniably --
it's a good thing.
It is a very good thing.
It's vastly preferable
to fiery rhetoric
and threats of nuclear war.
The problem isn't that Trump
is engaging in diplomacy.
The problem is that he doesn't
know what he's doing
and only cares about optics.
For example, at their
working lunch yesterday,
Trump asked photographers
to make sure
he and Kim looked good.
But watch Kim's face
after Trump's comment.
-Beautiful.
-[ Speaking Korean ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Okay. So now here I can --
If you are wondering, I can --
There's an explanation here.
You see,
he's a ruthless dictator.
That was the first time he's
ever heard that he's not thin.
[ Laughter ]
You're looking at a 10-time
"People's Republic"
Sexiest Man in the World.
[ Laughter ]
In fact, Trump is apparently
so obsessed with the optics
of this summit
that his White House
made an action-movie trailer
for the meeting
and played it for reporters
before his press conference.
Trump even said
he showed the trailer
to Kim Jong-un on an iPad.
Again, this is a real video
made by our White House.
♪♪
-7 billion people
inhabit planet Earth.
Of those alive today,
only a small number
will leave a lasting impact.
Destiny Pictures presents
a story of opportunity.
A new story, a new beginning,
one of peace.
Two men, two leaders,
one destiny.
Featuring President Donald Trump
and Chairman Kim Jong-un
in a meeting to remake history.
-Is that
an official White House video
or a direct-to-DVD movie
starring Steven Seagal?
[ Laughter ]
"The White House is under siege,
and only one President turned
karate master can stop them.
Steven Seagal stars
as President Trump
in 'Tae Kwon Donald.'"
[ Laughter ]
Of course, when President Obama
said he would meet
with North Korea
without pre-conditions,
Republicans mocked him
as naive and incompetent,
but, today, Trump supporters
are showering him with praise.
In fact, Trump even seemed
to make a major concession
to North Korea,
apparently without running it by
military officials
or South Korea first.
He promised to stop
joint military exercises
in the region.
Trump explained
his decision this way.
-We call them war games,
and I call them war games,
and they're
tremendously expensive.
The amount of money that
we spend on that is incredible.
We fly in bombers from Guam.
I said --
When I first started, I said,
"Where do the bombers
come from?"
Guam, nearby.
I said, "Oh, great, nearby.
Where's nearby?"
"6 1/2 hours."
6 1/2 hours?
That's a long time
for these big, massive planes
to be flying to South Korea
to practice, and then
drop bombs all over the place,
and then go back to Guam.
I know a lot about airplanes.
[ Laughter ]
-You know a lot about airplanes?
Because people who know
a lot about airplanes
don't have to say,
"I know a lot about airplanes."
[ Laughter ]
If you got on a flight,
you would be worried
if you heard your pilot say,
"We're expecting some
light turbulence
on our way to sunny Florida.
Should take about 3 1/2 hours.
Thanks for flying Delta.
I know a lot about airplanes."
[ Laughter ]
Again, diplomacy, so much better
than threats of war,
and if this summit
ratchets down the tension,
then that's a good thing.
We just have to hope
Trump doesn't mess it up,
because when it comes
to messing things up...
-That's what I do.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]